difficile victoire de l'équipe de france
il aura fallu attendre les prolongations
pour que les tricolores s'imposent face
au paraguay sans complexe un but de
laurent blanc à la 114e minute la
population kabyle en terre dans son
village natal lounès matoub la
souffrance et la colère de dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui ont accompagné
la dépouille du chanteur assassiné
l'ombre de la fraude sur les élections
régionales en corse des signatures
falsifié des électeurs en surnombre un
rapport a été déposé au conseil d'état
ouverture de la 12e conférence mondiale
sur le sida genève le virus ravage les
pays du tiers-monde où 90% de la
population n'a pas accès aux traitements
et puis la fête du cinéma jusqu'à mardi
soir des places à prix réduit la
fréquentation des salles subit
aujourd'hui la dure concurrence du
mondial
madame monsieur bonsoir la france ira
donc bien en quart de finale les
tricolores ont marqué la 114e minute de
jeu un but décisif
il aura fallu attendre les prolongations
pour que l'équipe de france puisse venir
à bout de la défense paraguayenne lionel
jospin parle d'un suspense à la
hitchcock et c'est vrai qu'il fallait
avoir le coeur bien accroché pour suivre
cette rencontre stade bollaert
christophe duchiron ça fait pas loin de
deux heures que les français c'est de
marquer et que les paraguayens résiste
et puis soudain il ya l'action toute la
france du football attend un but le but
qui envoie les bleus en quarts de finale
le but de laurent blanc qui met ça en
temps d'incertitudes tant
d'approximations
un but qui met fin aux mauvais rêve un
but qui va permettre aux bleus de
poursuivre un peu plus loin leur
aventure mais rendent hommage aux
joueurs du paraguay magnifique de
courage et qu'ils n'avaient que leurs
yeux pour pleurer la défaite
soyons honnêtes les français est
largement favori mais pas assez précis
en première période ils n'en finissent
pas de se casser les dents sur la
défense paraguay hier déjà il y a de
quoi faire la tête un peu avant la mi
temps
thierry henry rate une occasion en or
c'est le poteau qui renvoie 000 presque
sur toute la ligne
à la reprise chilavert embrasse sa
médaille magique et pour les bleus
crispé on craint le pire
sur toutes les paraguayens sont
dangereux bref c'est dur pour les nerfs
y compris pour zidane qui suit les
débats depuis le bord de touche
0 0 à la fin du temps réglementaire la
suite on la connaît
les prolongations et le but de laurent
blanc sur une belle remise de trezeguet
les sourires et les larmes de joie comme
un immense soulagement les bleus ont
frôlé la catastrophe
s'ils veulent être champions du monde
ils devront être meilleurs tellement
meilleur je vous propose tout de suite
d'écoutés à chaud la réaction à la
sortie des vestiaires de vic cents et
lizarazu et de laurent blanc le héros
des tricolores on les retrouve aux côtés
de yann lavoix et d'andré germain on
savait que bixente lizarazu bixente ça a
été un match très éprouvant pour les
nerfs
pour tous un les nerfs le physique on
est tombé sur une très belle équipe du
paraguay froid que il mérite amplement
cette qualification pour pour les
huitièmes de finale
car ils ont posé beaucoup de problèmes
si une équipe qui qui est super bien
organisé surtout qui a su changer son
organisation très souvent dans le match
oui laurent blanc qui a été en fait le
sauveur de l'équipe de france
aujourd'hui monté de l'arrière-garde
pour venir placer une frappe qui a
délivré l'équipe de france non je crois
qu'au bord c'est un travail collectif le
football est un sport collectif donc à
partir de là c'est pas celui qui marque
le but qu'il faut mettre à la basse et
toute l'équipe on a lutté on a lutté on
a été récompensé dans les dernières
minutes
ça faisait un moment que vous montiez à
la taca à l'assaut on sentait qu de
derrière vous aviez envie de les aider
sautes de vents maintenant on avait très
envie que ce soit moi marcel is how
lydien mais il fallait pas trop se
découvrir parce qu'on sentait que sur
quelques contres on a été on a été
quelquefois limitée à partir de là mais
bon il restait cinq minutes et à partir
de là j'ai pris la décision de mener un
petit peu mon jeu de tête puisque ont
évolué pratiquement qu'avec des grands
ballons devant
ça nous a réussi mais pour nous oui
c'est du pied finalement vous avez
marqué alors on fait sur une superbe
remise de david ce n'est pas en
remercier
quand j'ai marqué parce que bon c'est un
petit peu la foule dans ma tête mais là
j'ai revu le but je crois que le but et
est un drame de parti et son mérite
aussi
en attendant son retour à clairefontaine
dès ce soir pour pour l'équipe de france
et puis l'entraînement quand dès demain
merci beaucoup monsieur on a vu l'équipe
de france a été porté tout au long du
match par la ferveur des supporteurs qui
ont encouragé les tricolores face au
paraguay résistant et sans complexe
l'ambiance était tout aussi chaude aux
alentours du stade et la sortie du stade
reportage de philippe visseyrias rejet
motte ils font les fiers les supporters
français à la sortie du stade
mais le paraguay les a bien fait
souffrir pendant près de deux heures
on a eu peur mais on les a eus voulait
pas eu et on ira les supporters ont fait
deux fronts
avant le match
tous ceux qui n'ont pas pu obtenir de
billets s'étaient agglutinés dans les
bars de la ville
nous sommes ici au bollaert fief des
supporters lensois à quelques mètres du
stade
la ferveur qui est la même que dans les
tribunes la première fois que j à l'ange
parce que je voulais voir l'ambiance de
l'an justement pas la faute à maquiller
l'ambiance qui y règne est vraiment
génial
au fil des minutes le climat change
on comprend que la partie sera plus
difficile que prévu mais d'un verre de
bière on va gagner une scission on peut
voit perdre
pourquoi pas vrai on est là pour gagner
la finale on va gagner perdre en
huitièmes un scénario qu'il n'avait
jamais envisagé surtout face à une
équipe aussi méconnue que celle du
paraguay
mais le temps passe deuxième mi-temps
prolongation toujours pas de plan la
france si souveraines depuis le début du
mondial inquiète son public jusqu'à ce
qu'arrive laurent blanc
le public lensois se souviendra
longtemps de ce huitième de finale ce
devait être une formalité
ce fut une grosse frayeur
à
et puis de maputo mozambique jacques
chirac a suivi cette rencontre nos
envoyés spéciaux on peut recueillir sa
réaction à l'issue du match on écoute
contre le paraguay un vide à zéro mais
de vitesse qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je suis le plus heureux des hommes et
j'ai reçu des félicitations qui m'ont
touché droite au coeur de la part du
président chissano et je l'en remercie
angle n'avait pas eu le temps de
regarder le match bien sûr les
supporteurs dans quelques grandes villes
de france se sont rassemblés devant
d'immenses écrans géants comme à paris à
l'hôtel de ville on a vibré au rythme
des occasions manquées
enfin le soulagement avec le luth tant
attendu
et puis à bordeaux devant un écran géant
installé sur les quais de la garonne et
huit à dix mille supporteurs ont vécu
avec douleur et patient le match un
match pas toujours visibles tant la
foule était grande david bazié philippe
dumas y autant trouver une place
confortable car un huitième de finale
on ne sait pas combien de temps ça peut
durer presque dix mille supporters pour
voir où entre voir l'équipe de france on
y voit quelque chose d'ici n'ont pas
beaucoup mais c'est pas grave
l amiante comment vous allez connaître
le score alors les rapporter en centre
avec les bleus sont à l' attaquent les
supporters saute et écrit
mais au fait de joueurs ou d'orange
moi j'écris aimerait que les autres
parce que tout à l'heure où la cria fois
c'est normal et il n'y avait pas but
non madame trezeguet n'a pas marqué 0 0
à la mi temps les gaulois se prennent à
douter et certains voudraient bien
quitter les quais de la garonne pour
fouler la pelouse lensoise
vous avez le maillot où j'espérais
entrer en seconde mi temps mais
carrément on va tous rentrer et on va
essayer de le remettre à ne serait-ce
qu'un même la moitié d'un an sans fumée
mais plus le temps s'écoule plus la
tension monte une prière pour un but qui
tarde guitare
j'ai eu un peu peur en deuxième mi temps
mais j'y croyais toujours je revends la
liesse de la victoire oubliez le doute
et déjà les pronostics du quart de
finale contre l'italie
le joueur thierry henry qui a participé
un peu plus de la première mi-temps est
sorti du stade bollaert sur une civière
il souffre d'une légère entorse à la
cheville
on ignore encore s'il pourra participer
aux quarts de finale contre l'italie
on imagine l'émotion de sa maman tout au
long de cette rencontre alexandre kara
et olivier robert ont suivi le match en
sa compagnie pour tous les jouets du
monde cyril le neveu de thierry henry
n'aurait pas rater ce match devant la
télé pour voir jouer tonton il y à
grand-mère et maman aussi regarder son
fils à la télé madame henri n'aime pas
beaucoup cet exercice vous regardez
toujours les matchs de vos six n'ont
jamais toujours après
ça mais jamais avant la mi temps arrive
et toujours pas de but mais chez nous on
rit on est du genre optimiste mais
j'espère qu'ils vont gagner mais
beaucoup beaucoup de beaux pronostics
en effet le suspense du entière mais
voilà thierry henry blessé doit sortir
le match lui continue et finalement une
délivrance
franchement une délivrance dans ce
qu'ils méritaient de gagner
ils ont trop donné vraiment trop donné
trop trop trop trop donné surtout henry
blessé à la cheville ce soir maman
attend des nouvelles du fiston en
algérie les sanglots de la population
kabyle sous une chaleur écrasante ils
étaient des dizaines de milliers
assister à l'enterrement du chanteur
assassiné lounès matoub dans son petit
village natal certains vais marcher
toute la nuit pour rendre un dernier
hommage à leurs martyrs reportage de
notre équipe sur place redouane salies
commentaires thierry thulliez recouvert
du drapeau national algérien veillé par
sa mère
lounès matoub repose dans sa maison dans
les rues du petit village kabyle ou
matoub aînés sont bien trop étroite pour
accueillir la foule des anonymes
ils sont venus de toute la kabylie
certains ont même osé traversée de nuit
la montagne repères pourtant des groupes
armés dans la région les femmes
n'assistent normalement pas aux obsèques
l'hommage à lounès matoub a balayé la
tradition
l'oeuvre
je suis venu pour pouvoir mettre tout vu
pour la dernière fois en fait on est
prêts pour notre homme en fuite un grand
choc une grande perte mais très vite
l'émotion cède la colère comme ces deux
derniers jours à tizi ouzou un slogan
est repris pouvoir assassin comme si la
foule reprocher aux autorités
algériennes une quelconque complicité
dans l'assassinât du chanteur
le parti d'opposition démocrates dont
était proche le laisse matthew n'hésite
en tout cas pas à poser la question des
artistes qui ont une fonction sociale
aussi importante disparaissent cela veut
dire que les forces du mal sont
importantes et sa disparition pose le
vrai problème des complicités au kabylie
qui ont permis à ce contenu
de l'éliminer
ce soir nessma tous propose ici quelques
mètres devant sa maison dans son village
natal comme il l'avait souhaité et puis
l'on vient d'apprendre la mort d'un
autre manifestant à kabylie depuis le
décès de lounès matoub et les émeutes
qui ont suivi à tizi ouzou c'est la
troisième victime qui est à déplorer en
france maintenant à marseille mais aussi
à paris rassemblement notamment au
trocadéro sur le parvis des droits de
l'homme quelques 500 personnes s'y sont
retrouvés en milieu d'après midi parmi
lesquels jack lang bébéar jacques
higelin ou ferhat cet artiste
d'algériens qui pleurait son frère
place de la république plus de 5000
personnes disaient leur tristesse leur
désespoir autour d'une immense photo
noir et blanc de lounès matoub
le chanteur berbère symbole de toute une
jeunesse continuera de vivre dans la
mémoire de tous françoise joly eh ben
c'est sale elle vacille de chagrin vous
jeunesse qui est exilé qu'on a obligé de
fuir le pays
comme ça a été mon cas voulu émigrer
nous sommes impuissants devant la
réalité on fait comment pour malika
domrane est l'une des voix les plus
connus de la chanson berbère
cet après midi à sa manière à paris elle
rendait hommage à son ami lounès matoub
et c'est soutenu par la foule qu'elle va
entonner un chant funèbre
une complainte kabyle
pour cet enterrement symbolique souhaité
par la communauté berbère place de la
république
les gens qui l'ont assassiné
on va plus l'arraché à cette communauté
qu'en fait on a enterré dans leur coeur
et quitte à chacun aujourd'hui
mais l'émotion n'était pas la seule à
s'exprimer dans cette foule il y avait
aussi de la colère ils ont crié pouvoir
assassin comme en écho aux voix qui
résonnait ce matin dans les montagnes de
kabylie au bout de leurs bras des
drapeaux amazigh berbère un hommage fait
de larmes et de révolte
en turquie après le violent tremblement
de terre qui a secoué le sud du pays les
secours poursuivent leurs recherches
notamment à dana cette agglomération de
plusieurs millions d'habitants
sévèrement touchée par le séisme le
bilan fait état d'au moins 110 morts et
1500 blessés
les hôpitaux sont débordés et de
nombreux rescapés ont passé la nuit à la
belle étoile valérie ermite sans relâche
et sans trop d'espoir toute la nuit en
vain et secouristes ont tenté de dégager
de nouvelles victimes
la majorité d'entre elles sont décédées
le bilan s'élève pour l'instant à 110
morts et au moins à 1500 blessés
la région n'est pas habitué à des
tremblements de terre de cette ampleur
car nous ne sommes pas la zone la plus à
risque
merci à dieu qu'il y ait pas plus de
victimes ici ou dans d'autres provinces
plus de soixante cinq répliques ont été
ressenties depuis la secousse principale
alors les habitants presserait dormir à
même le sol
effrayés par la violence du séisme ou
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'avaient
plus vraiment le choix
une ville comme c'est en eau sud du pays
seraient détruites à 20% distribution de
vivres et premiers soins sommaires les
hôpitaux de la région sont débordés le
président turc a rendu hommage aux
secours en tentant de réconforter les
blessés
pendant ce temps d'autres à la chaîne
pose les tombes
l'ombre de la fraude de sur les
élections régionales en corse un dossier
déposé devant le conseil d'état dénonce
des manoeuvres douteuses apparemment des
signatures falsifié des électeurs en
surnombre ont émaillé ce scrutin c'est
l'union du peuple corse un parti
autonomiste dirigée par le docteur
simioni qui a déposé ce recours valérie
fournier jean pierre pasteur d'un nom à
l'autre la même signature pour tout le
monde des anomalies de ce type porterait
sur 178 bureaux de vote en corse
c'est cet homme qui dénonce la fraude
françois alfonsi militants de l'upc
l'union du peuple corse un parti
autonomiste qui a déposé un dossier
devant le conseil d'état pour
manipulation lors des dernières
régionales et des cantonales notamment
pour de fausses domiciliations comme ici
dans le 8e canton du bastia donc voici
le logement dans lequel ont été
déclarées la résidence de quatre
électeurs fictifs donc parfaite des
électeurs qui habitent ailleurs dans
bastia mais que l'on a fait voter ici
donc subite c'était des fermetés dans ce
conte où exactement parce que ce canton
est un canton très disputée et qui
intéresse énormément les services
municipaux de bastia pour gagner les
élections cantonales derrière une boîte
aux lettres plus un compteur edf et le
tour est joué
ce qui a permis de découvrir le
pot-aux-roses ici c'est que nous avons
demandé une enquête au pénal et que le
procureur a suivi et a donc eu enquête
de police et c'est la police qui est
venue constater l'état de délabrement de
l'adresse de ses soi-disant électeurs
les policiers ont ainsi constaté que
cinquante électeurs n'habitait pas à
l'adresse indiquée ce canton a même vu
sa population augmenter subitement avec
37 % de votants en plus aucun électeur
ne s'est plaint d'avoir voté sans voter
silence complice ou intimidation lie à
toute force
deux méthodes ça va du bon d'être social
savoie billets de 500 francs savoir
président r la machine à laver quoi 900
enfants des chutes impact une voie puis
à lumio il y a beaucoup de résidences
d'été pourtant presque tout le monde à
voter même les malades les absents et
les signatures se ressemblent monsieur
huet qui est malade sur le continent
depuis environ un an et demi qu'il ne
peut pas se déplacer qui donc n'a pas pu
voter et une deuxième un dôme ali qui
concerne monsieur change rue poilâne qui
a quitté la corse depuis un an et demi
et qui à mon avis n'a pas pu voter
d'ailleurs sa signature ici au bas d'un
document ne correspond pas du tout à
celle apposée sur la liste d'émargement
on après tout à l'heure la mort de
jacques pilhan ex conseiller en
communication de françois mitterrand
mais aussi de jacques chirac ce
publicitaire qui avait pendant 11 ans
travaillé aux côtés de françois
mitterrand est décédé à l'âge de 54 ans
des suites d'un cancer du poumon jacques
chirac avait également fait appel à ses
services après son élection en mai 95
jacques milan avait travaillé en
collaboration étroite avec claude chirac
la fille du président
les deux réacteurs nucléaires du nouveau
porte avions français le charles de
gaulle ont été mis en marche il ya tout
juste quelques jours et les premiers
essais en mer du premier porte avions
européens à propulsion nucléaire
pourront débuter comme prévu à l'automne
pour l'instant le bâtiment français et
aker brest reportage jean-claude allanic
rejet mathurin ce sera le joyau de la
marine nationale le premier et l'unique
porte avions à propulsion nucléaire en
europe
un bâtiment de 40 mille tonnes ancrés
dans le port de brest
en attendant les premiers essais en mer
à l'automne opérationnel le charles de
gaulle sera une véritable ville
flottante 2000 personnes à bord dont une
centaine pour s'occuper de la partie
nucléaire sur le pont de 160 mètres de
long
24 avions seront prêts à décoller à tout
moment sans être gênés par les cheminées
du porte avion puisqu'il nous on attend
la présence des cheminées a deux
inconvénients d'abord de prendre des
surfaces de pont d'envol qui sont des
surfaces précieuse et d'autre part dans
certaines phases de vol et en
particulier à la propagent de créer des
courants d'air chaud au moment où
l'avion se présente
à proximité du porte avions et donc de
créer des problèmes d'importance
derrière cette porte blindée
les deux chaufferies nucléaires du
charles de gaulle l'endroit est classé
secret défense
seules les caméras de l'armée sont
autorisés la puissance des réacteurs est
elle aussi un secret militaire sait
seulement qu'ils peuvent chacun 900
tonnes qu'ils ont une autonomie d'une
douzaine d'années et que leur première
monte en puissance
les spécialistes disent dit l'urgence
vient d'être engagé ça veut dire que la
réaction de fission a commencé et donc
on commence à monter en température et
peu à peu on va faire tous les essais
qui permettront de mettre leurs acteurs
côté sécurité tout a été prévu pour
préserver les marins il environnement
protégé par des blindages exceptionnel
les chaufferies nucléaires sont
officiellement à l'abri de tout risque
de fuite radioactive
même si le porte avions était bombardée
l'aspect nucléaire nous a servi à faire
un bâtiment extrêmement sûr extrêmement
sécuritaire et qui peut sans problème
affrontait bien évidemment les
opérations sinon ça n'aurait pas de sens
de faire un bateau qu'ils ne puissent
pas affronter des opérations de guerre
coup du charles de gaulle 19 milliards
de francs le prix à payer pour faire de
la france la deuxième puissance maritime
nucléaire au monde après les états unis
je n'ai à l'ouverture de la 12ème
conférence mondiale sur le sida
aujourd'hui dans le monde près de 31
millions de personnes vivent avec le
virus et parmi elles la grande majorité
de malades ou de sujets séropositifs se
trouve dans le tiers-monde
aux etats-unis par exemple il faut
savoir que pour le sida les soins sont
entièrement prises en charge à travers
des aides financières et la gratuité des
médicaments
en revanche pour tous ceux qui sont
contaminés qui aimerait continuer
travailler
le choix est redoutable car s'ils
reprennent leur emploi ils perdent toute
subvention
dominique derda s'est rendu dans le
delaware où 12% de la population est
noire dans 63% est atteinte par le virus
portrait d'un de ces jeunes malades qui
aimeraient se réinsérer
chaque jour parce que la lutte contre le
sida il son combat de chaque jour
pour elle rend visite à ses clients
comme elle les appelle au libre en jet
assistante sociale à wilmington dans le
delaware et son client ce matin si
william hill à 29 ans il est homosexuel
toxicomanes et depuis cinq ans
séropositif jamais je me suis dit un
jour tu vas mourir je veux pas y penser
je me disais simplement ce qui doit
arriver arrivera en ce moment où william
se sont plutôt bien il suit une cure de
désintoxication et n'a plus touché à
l'héroïne dit il depuis trois ou quatre
mois
tous ces frais médicaux la trithérapie
ses séjours à l'hôpital deux sont prises
en charge gratuitement
et puisqu'il ne travaille pas il reçoit
de l'état 3000 francs par mois
je veux travailler je trouver un job
faire quelque chose quoi j'en peux plus
traîner ici à tourner en rond ou à
rester au lit toute la journée
j'en huige des primes grâce aux progrès
de la médecine et aux nouveaux
traitements ou williams peut vivre avec
sa maladie mais s'il trouvait un travail
même un petit boulot ils perdraient
automatiquement toutes les aides qu'il
reçoit et devraient payer de sa poche
les médicaments qui le maintiennent dans
ya encore besoin quand un malade n'avait
plus que deux ans à vivre tenir avec ses
3000 francs par mois ça pouvait aller
maintenant quand on vous dit tout votre
ville vous faudra tenir avec cette fois
mille francs par mois c'est pas très
enthousiasmant c'est bien là le dilemme
qui se pose et c'est un problème
national car les malades vivent plus
longtemps
voilà pourquoi cette année encore lebron
dj organisera une nouvelle marche contre
le sida parce que même dans un pays
riches comme les états unis il faut
toujours plus d'argent parce que malgré
toutes les campagnes de prévention le
nombre de séropositifs ne cesse
d'augmenter
bill clinton à pékin pour une journée
plutôt touristique entouré de sa famille
il s'est promené le long de la grande
muraille de chine
auparavant le président américain
assister à un office religieux et a
plaidé pour la liberté religieuse
bill clinton qui à plusieurs reprises a
déclaré qu'il voulait pouvoir parler
directement chinois durant ce voyage à
shanghai où doit se rendre mardi et
mercredi
ces dissidents demain
la rencontre et bill clinton et menacent
d'entamer une grève de la faim s'ils
sentent arrêté jacques chirac est arrivé
au mozambique pour une visite de 24
heures auparavant le président français
a remis la légion d'honneur à
monseigneur desmond tutu prix nobel de
la paix et ancien archevêque du cap qui
a beaucoup oeuvré pour la réconciliation
une cérémonie qui s'est déroulée lors
d'un déjeuner offert par le coup dans la
rue en présence notamment de l'écrivain
andré brink un premier référendum
démocratique au portugal
huit millions et demi d'électeurs
doivent se prononcer sur la
libéralisation de l'avortement une
question éminemment délicate qui divise
les clivages dans ce pays à majorité
catholique existe dans la plupart des
grands partis et d'après les premières
indications
on s'oriente vers un taux d'abstention
record richard binet philippe jasselin
hier encore le sujet était tabou
aujourd'hui l on parle librement en
plein centre de lisbonne
moi je pense que cette décision revient
à la femme est en couple un nlhe à
retenir et l'enfant dans tout ça parce
qu'on lui demande son avis n'a pas
aujourd'hui huit millions et demi de
portugais ont dû répondre à cette
question
si oui ni non une femme peut-elle
interrompre volontairement sa grossesse
plat figueras les partisanes de l'ibg
sont en campagne
des militants de la première heure qui
depuis des années dénonce l'hypocrisie
de la loi
tout le monde sait que des femmes
avortent clandestinement au portugal
environ vingt trente mille par an celles
qui en ont les moyens vont en espagne et
les autres font appel à des sages femmes
avec tous les risques que cela
représente
cela non pas 20 ans ils font partie de
la bourgeoisie portugaises sont
étudiants à l'université catholique de
lisbonne et font campagne pour le non
c'est un foetus de dix semaines vous
voyez de dix semaines
images chocs violence des mots que l'on
soit pour ou contre
au portugal parler de l'avortement s'est
avivé les passions c'est pas bien ce que
vous dites c'est pas bien j'ai 64 ans
est gelée déjà fait oui j'ai avorté
et vous voudriez enlever ce droit depuis
l'enfant depuis l'annnonce du référendum
l'église pèse de tout son poids dans la
campagne à fatima au lieu de la
chrétienté deux portugais sur 300
pratiquants
ici pas d' affiches ni de manifestations
tonitruante un bon prêche vaut mieux que
tous les discours
quant au riz qui leur est commune l'on
oserait on ne veut pas approuver une loi
qui va contre le roi du bon dieu mais tu
n'as tu as pas cher qu'une chose qu'il
faut faire
wade états majors politiques kaïs un
bourg d'agriculteurs ont créé à sa
colline c'est peut-être là dans un de
ces petits villages du nord que se
jouera une partie du scrutin la mairie a
beau être socialiste et militer en
faveur du oui ici c'est dieu qui
commande et ce sera nous entamerions ya
des femmes d'aujourd'hui ouanaminthe de
mettre leurs chansons mais n'ont pas
honte de relever leur jus pour les faire
ce sont des gens très religieux qui vont
à l'église et au catéchisme mais je
pense qu'un jour ils franchiront le pas
selon les derniers sondages le oui
l'emporterait mais le portugal rural
restera hostiles à l'avortement et les
femmes de galice devront encore
longtemps s'exiler pour avorter loi du
regard des leurs les partisans de
l'accord de paix pour l'irlande du nord
sont les vainqueurs des élections les
résultats sont définitifs depuis hier
soir
76 des 108 sièges reviennent aux
candidats favorables à la paix le
premier ministre britannique tony blair
s'est dit très confiant dans l'avenir
dans la nouvelle assemblée les
protestants unionistes modéré constitue
la première formation avec 28 sièges
david trimble sera donc élue premier
ministre les nationalistes modérés
disposeront quant à eux de 24 sièges
en mémoire de la princesse diana concert
de charité dans le domaine familial des
spencer à althorp ouvert depuis hier au
public
la ferveur de cette foule qui a attendu
des heures durant pour écouter cliff
richard doux laisser garrett la soprano
britannique etienne leenhardt
voici donc le préambule de l'été diana
des maïs et des miles de bouchons hier
soir aux environs de la propriété
familiale des spencer pour le premier
rassemblement cette année des
inconditionnels de la paces on tenait à
venir dans sa maison ont donné un peu
d'argent et assister au concert bien sûr
qu'on vient proviennent arc pour honorer
sa mémoire est d'ailleurs hier nous
étions en france au pont de l'alma pour
voir exactement l'endroit où elle est
morte
quinze mille personnes se sont donc
bousculer ce week-end dans le domaine
d'althorp sur fond de polémique quant au
reversement des bénéfices les vedettes
les plus célèbres avait décliné
l'invitation
la mère diana et surtout son jeune frère
le comte spencer organisateurs du
spectacle ont tout de même promis que
sur les 400 francs que coûte et l'entrée
130 seraient reversés à des oeuvres
caritatives
quant aux habitants du village de gouabo
hington ce premier événement
commémoratif leur donne plutôt la gueule
de bois
marcel un français est venu habiter ici
il ya 15 ans il recherchait le cadre
soit sera le premier peut-être le
dernier cancer comme son et pourtant
dans trois jours où le sort pourrir à
son musée diana et sa promenade autour
de la tombe de la princesse
on attend d'ici fin août 150 mille
personnes et les mauvaises langues de
considérer déjà que ce diana landes qui
ouvre ses portes mercredi est beaucoup
plus un coup de marketing que l'hommage
ému d'un jeune homme à sa soeur disparue
grand prix de france de formule 1 avec
la victoire de michael schumacher sur
ferrari sur le circuit de magny cours
hakkinen conserve toutefois la tête du
championnat du monde laurent frédéric
bollée
la ola à magny cours ambiance football
dans la nièvre le match au sommet
opposant n'est fait la finlande de mika
hakkinen à la toujours solides allemagne
de michael schumacher l'allemand dont la
concentration fait merveille au départ
c'est lui qui prend le meilleur envol au
nez et à la barbe des pilotes mclaren
le sort du 84e grand prix de france
vient de se jouer dès les premières
secondes encore mieux pour ferrari et
dior vannes a réussi à se placer en
deuxième position la scuderia de nouveau
en pleine possession de ses moyens pour
mika hakkinen la course d'attentes
commencé peu avant la mi-temps plutôt la
mi-course coup de théâtre
le finlandais est parti en tête à queue
il repart sans perdre trop de temps mais
les espoirs d'avant course se sont
envolés le mieux régner
je déteste perdre je pense que c'est
pareil pour tous les autres ça rend
heureux et je vous le recommande
fair play le finlandais car dans la
paroisse de magny cours
la messe est dite le baron rouge
schumacher fait un sans-faute domination
totale et retour dans la course au
championnat du monde
l'allemand empoche sa 30e victoire en
devançant son coéquipier heures vannes
qui jusqu'au bout va résister au retour
de mika hakkinen
le finlandais essaye tout mais rien à
faire l'irlande et s'accroche et offre
sous les yeux de madame aquitaine le
premier doublé de ferrari depuis huit
ans lors d'une coupe du monde c'est
normal il faut toujours se méfier d'une
équipe qui réunit à la fois l'allemagne
et l'italie
depuis midi aujourd'hui jusqu'à mardi
soir la fête du cinéma 14e édition du
genre mais en plein mondial la
fréquentation des salles pourrait pâtir
de la concurrence notamment du match que
vous êtes tout à l'heure la france au
paraguay
ce film est l laurent hamida grâce à ce
passeport vous payez la première séance
au prix fort mais seulement 10 francs
pour toutes celles qui suivent trois
jours durant le septième art casse ses
prix et les cinéphiles en profite pour
faire le plein d'imagés des kilomètres
depuis dit qu elle engloutit en un
minimum de temps
attention à l'indigestion aujourd'hui on
commence un peu tard donc on envoie
croix vient de m'en faire 5 ya pas de
menc à optimiser le parcours les
habitués commence par sélectionner un
quartier voilà on y est
avant d'étudier consciencieusement les
horaires pour un enchaînement parfait
maintenant on a voulu tout fish 6
milliards pour cette 14e édition de la
fête du cinéma le public a certes
l'embarras du choix
cinquante trois fils sont sortis sur les
écrans en juin seulement voilà côté
qualité nous sommes laissés dire que le
programme aurait pu être plus excitant
et comme en plus comble de malchance
cette première journée s'offrait d'au
moins deux sérieux handicap même sorte
les pieds là-bas des sols côté femmes et
l'attrait du fou de côté hommes
du coup la foule était d'ailleurs et les
salles n'ont pas affiché complet les
exploitants de salles n'atteindront
probablement pas le niveau record de
l'an dernier c'est 4 millions de
spectateurs
à moins d'une bonne surprise d'ici mardi
soir ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
en rappelle les principaux titres
difficile victoire de l'équipe de france
il aura fallu attendre les prolongations
pour que les tricolores s'imposent face
au paraguay sans complexe la butte de
laurent blanc à la 114e minute la
population kabyle en terre dans son
village natal lounès matoub la
souffrance et la colère de dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui ont accompagné
la dépouille du chanteur assassiné la
météo dans un instant présentée par
valérie alexandre fui rendez-vous à
20h50 sur notre chaîne pour le match au
stade de france nigeria à danemark
demain dans les 4 vérités marie pierre
farkas recevra joseph blatter président
de la fédération internationale de
football
demain soir à 20h vous retrouverez
daniel bilalian je vous remercie de
votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2